this video is about the
kuske wallace test we go through together what the
kursk wallace test is and how it can be calculated and
interpreted and at the end of
this video i will show you
how you
can easily calculate the kuske wallace test online
if you have the
want to read up on topics from this video again
just take a look at our book statistics made
easy the link will give you a video
description and with that we will start
the kursk wallace test is a
hypothesis test which can
be used if you want to search there is whether
it  there is a difference between several
independent groups now you may
be surprised and say hey
with several independent
groups I use a variant analysis
that is correct but if your data are not
normally distributed and the
prerequisites for the variance analysis are
not met  the crystal
waters test to use
the crystal waters test is not
parametric counterpart to a factor
all variance analysis what that means
i will show you now
between the two tests there is a
crucial difference
the variance analysis checks whether there is a
mean value difference so when
we have our groups we calculate
the mean value of each group and
see if  are these averages all the
same or not
at cross the wall is first
we don't check if the averages are the same
but if the rank totals are the same
what does that mean now what is your rank
what is a slow at the course level
is the actual values ​​are not
used  instead, all people
are sorted by size and assigned a
rank the person with the
lowest value is assigned value 1
or rank one,
let's say that's our smallest person,
then we look at the second smallest
person, who is given rank two,
let's say that  here is our two
smallest persons doing the same
wi  r then with the third smallest
person we give the rank three and so
on and so on until all persons
have been assigned a rank
now we have assigned each person the
rank that the respective person
has then we can simply
add up all the ranks from the first group
from the second group
summing up all the ranks and from the third
group summing up all the ranks in this
case we get that in the first group
a slow of 54 in the second
group we get a slow of 70
and if we sum up all the ranks in
the third group we get a
rank sum of 47 out the huge
advantage is if we don't use the
mean values ​​but the rank
sums then the data doesn't have to be
normally distributed so in the crash test
your data doesn't have to be normally
distributed before we now how to
calculate the course wanted test don't
worry  it's really easy let's take a look at
the requirements first
when do you use the course kolles test
you only use the course
when you have a nominal or original
variable with more than two
values ​​and
also a metric
or original variable you have a nominal or
original variable, for example,
when you look at your preferred newspaper
watch with the values ​​bild faz
and south german newspaper or the
frequency of television with the
values ​​daily several times a week
seldom or never that is then a
so-called independent variable a
metric or an original variable
you would have for example if you
have the variable salary the well-being
moda  the body weight that would then be
your dependent variable
what exactly are the requirements now
there simply have to be several independent
random samples with at least original
scaled characteristics the
variables do not have to fulfill a distribution curve
the new hypothesis for the kowoll course
is the independent ones
samples all have the same
central tendency and are therefore from
the same population or
alternatively said the independent
samples all have the same sum
the alternative hypothesis is at least
one of the independent samples does
not have the same central tendency as
the other samples and is therefore
from a different one  basic population or
again alternatively expressed at least
one of the independent samples has a
different rank total than the
other samples how do you
calculate a crash test that is not difficult
let's say you have measured the reaction times of
three groups group a group b
and group c and want to know if  there is
a difference between the groups
you have listed the measured values ​​in
a table and we
simply assume that these values ​​are
not normally distributed, so we have to
use the course wanted test
and cannot use the variance analysis
ve  Using our hypothesis, there is
no difference between the groups,
so the reaction time in group A is
the same as in group B and as in
group C
, first of all, we assign a
rank to each person.
33 is the smallest value
, so this person is ranked
134  is the second smallest value this
person gets the rank
25 and 30 is the third smallest value
this person gets the third place
and so on and so on
that would be bad have the last rank with
twelve
now we can go and
calculate the slowness of the groups  and the
average rank of the slow ones can
be easily calculated for
the group, the sum of the ranks is simply
two plus four plus 7 + 9, which equals
22 since we have four people in group a
, our average rank
is 22 divided by four  which equals 5.5 firmly
we now do the same for the
second group here we simply calculate
that 5 + 11 +1 which equals 27
and for d  We get the mean rank total
from 27 34, which equals 6.75 for
the third group, like a rank
total of 29 and a mean
wang total of 7 25, so now we
know the slow
and the middle slow of each group  if there is no
difference between the three groups
, the ranks should actually be
evenly distributed among the three
groups, so we can
now calculate the
expected banks we get the expected rank by calculating the
number of participants plus 1
and dividing it by two  in
our case it is 12 + 1 divided by two which is
easily 6.5 so in each group or
for each person the expected rank is
6.5 so we now have almost everything
we need
we asked twelve people the
expected value of the ranks is 6  ,5
we calculated the mean rank sums of the
individual groups, the
degrees of freedom in our case are two,
which result simply from the
number of  groups - 1 therefore wide -
once that equals two and
lastly we need the variance
the variance of ranks results from
this formula renault 2 - 1 divided by 12 n
is again the number of people
so we have 12 2 - 1 divided by twelve
In our case, this results in 11.92. Now
we have everything together
with these values. If we
now have the test variable, we can calculate the test
variable h corresponds to the square of the value and
it results from this formula. 1 is
again the number of cases where Gaddafi is
the mean rank sum of the individual
groups and it is the expected
value of the ranks memorial squared is the variance of the ranks in our
case the number of cases is 12
we always have four people per group
so we can pull out the mobile phone 55 is
the mean rank  So the first
group 6.75 is the mean rank sum of
the second group and 7.25 is the
slow of the third group
so we get a haar value rounded
from 0  ,5 as said this value
corresponds to the squared value so
we can now simply read the squared value in the
table of the critical squared values
therefore we have two degrees of
freedom and let's
assume that we have a significant level
of 0 05 then we get  a
critical square value of 5.91 our
value is of course smaller heat
critical c square value and thus
the null hypothesis is maintained why the
work i square value we calculated is
smaller than the critical
square will then based on the
available data the
keep the new hypothesis and don't discard it
now you know the basics for the kiosk
wallace test and i'll show you
how you can easily calculate the kluske wallace test
online with data tab
for this you simply
visit day.de you can find the link in the video
description click on the statistics
calculator and add your data to this
table 1 table learn
and  copy your own data
then click on this tag
tsg square test and hannover under
this tag a lot of hypothesis
tests are bundled and datatec
automatically suggests the right test
after you have copied the data into the
table you can see the
reaction time and group below  we
simply click on reaction time and
group and datatec automatically calculates
a variance analysis
, but we don't want to calculate a variance analysis here, we want to calculate the non-
parametric test,
so we simply uncheck the box
now calculates and the state app has automatically
become the course  means we also
get a square value of 0.5 out the
degree of freedom is in two and we
get a ph value of 0.77
recalculated down here you can also
read the interpretation in words a
larger test showed that it had no
significant influence  between the
categories the p value is 07 7  9
this keeps the new
hypothesis and rejects the alternative
hypothesis i hope you enjoyed the video
and see you next
time